дело в том что мета вселенную я наблюдаю
уже везде по сути для меня метавселенной
то обман google бег убери поначалу .
даже сейчас мы можем прогуляться по 1
метр вселенной сегодня будут кинжалом
хейтерам
негатив щекам который дает ребят и там
по снам и не туда идем там пропасть
порнографии кстати очень много
равиль заставил
[музыка]
у
вас есть представления почему мы назвали
этот подкаст гемба подкаст
версиями версий начнем с рамы ли версия
общей разговаривать general
негде будет я понял я просто подстроку
что
я
был google by клубе прошёл очень
интересно
мне кажется как-то связан с кайзером
односторонне мешаем все так по любому
это японское слово даст японским едим
нибудь под текстом по душе по-другому у
нас вас не может кордон
волшеб всем подходит хорошо вот почему
почему мы назвали подкаст гемба подкаст
смотрите в японской философии в к-1
философии гембэ это дословно называется
то самое место то самое место
или и еще или еще буквально если
перевести реальное место то есть это то
место где
производится
ценность для потребителя то есть там где
происходит процесс по созданию ценности
для потребителя этот термин был
заимствован из кайзен технологий и вот
именно в цеху либо где вот в колл-центре
у кого где производится ценность для
потребителя именно там место называется
гемба и когда там случается любая
проблема все руководители компании сразу
же идут на гембл то есть они идут в то
место где возникла проблема в
соответствии с японской технологии
обязательно нужно идти прежде всего туда
где возникла проблема и принимать
решение там на game by и надо смотреть
на контекст выясняют задать этот вопрос
почему выяснить корневую причину и
принять решение о том
как устранить эту проблему но самое
главное главный смысл который мне
понравился это то место где создается
ценность для потребителя это первое и
второе это цех это земля это не высокие
кабинеты это все равно что пойти в народ
пойти в цех и разобраться в сути
проблемы на месте разобраться сути
проблемы на месте так вот наша гемба
подразумевает что мы объявляем каждые
две недели обсуждаем какую-то тему или
проблему которую там будоражат
общественное мнение который на хайпе и
выходим как бы вот так в поле и
обсуждаем и
пытаемся при этом не просто обсуждать у
нас не просто bull sheet for нас равиль
заставил мы мы мы стараемся принести
какую-то пользу чтобы люди получили
какой-то инсайд от нашего общения и так
переходим к теме сегодняшнего нашего
подкаста тема сегодняшнего нашего
подкаста мета вселенная вы наверное все
об этом уже слышали последние полгода
это нашумевшая тема фейсбук объявил о
том что они переименовывают свою
компанию
компании-владельца
социальной сети фейсбук и инстаграм
ватсап в компанию мета и по этому поводу
было очень много хайпа везде очень много
об этом говорили и это с одной стороны
вот всегда вообще это знаете похоже как
снег в астане постоянно для акимата это
полная неожиданность так и здесь ну
метод по моему мнению это вселенной оно
уже наступило во многих местах и она уже
есть то просто в какой-то матрас кто-то
щелкай объявляет и вдруг как будто она в
россии появилась на самом деле это такой
процесс поступательный итак давайте
просто пройдемся что вы думаете по
поводу вот как каждый из нас понимает
что документа вселенная
просто ответки да ну какая я согласен
кстати что это просто сейчас обозначили
неким словом которое
скажем объединила но некоторые
инициативы который уже несколько лет
существует для помощи в 2016 году мы
были как раз вот фейсбуке тогда они уже
купили вот oculus rift они показывали
чего они достигли с точки зрения we are
a
классных принципе да действительно игры
где-то переносишься и твой мозг
действительно очень круто переносится в
некое пространство
нереальная до при этом у тебя есть
полное ощущение что это действительно ну
вот то самое пространство ты понимаешь
что ты стоишь на земле но ты боишься
шагнуть вперед потому что перед тобой
пропасть в виртуальное но пропасть да и
ты действительно боишься шагнуть вперед
нас мозга тяжело
где-то перестроиться и вот поверить что
там все-таки
та же комната где ты был момент там на
диване очков я
думаю что это
[музыка]
действительно будущее мне кажется что
она не такое близкое у меня есть
ощущение что
те проблемы которые слышат существу это
не обязательно будет решен и с точки
зрения удобства ношения различных
гаджетов с точки зрения реалистичности с
точки зрения
того к этому когда большое количество
разработчиков подключиться и будет это
будущее момент усилий нарисовать
я думаю что это горизонт может быть 10
20 лет примерно так но это будет
поступать на движение вперед я помню еще
в 2016 году в том же самом googl'e и
разговаривали про то как что-то улучшить
многократно и разговор был про то как
улучшить многократном возможность
работать например как сделать так чтобы
не ты ходил на работу работы приходила к
тебе ну там как раз вот эти штуки да как
улучшить многократно возможность учиться
взаимодействовать с людьми со всего мира
и
действительно какие-то вещи уже
существуют то есть те кто одевал
какие-то качественные очки играл 2-ве
игры вы наверняка понимаете да что это
прикольно это действительно прикольно
заставляет задуматься это
зачастую во много раз круче чем было до
но при этом мне кажется что эта
вселенная это точно какая-то часть
большая но не генеральная часть нашей
будущей жизни мне это кажется то есть я
бы наверно не стал возводить это формат
о точно это скажем
гембл
the place to be это это не так что это
какая-то огромная часть нашей же это
важная часть это большая часть
но она же где-то и пугающим и кажется у
людей хватит здравого смысла
не уйти туда полностью матрица не
превратится какой-нибудь там я надеюсь я
я верю что так и будет но по твоему
мнению
мета вселенной это определённый такой
другой мир зеркало реального мира или
другой нам возможность туда зайти то
есть скажем так и так вот есть как это
градусы
[музыка]
режиссер да что что то такое то есть это
это такое extension к нашему миру такое
расширение то есть у тебя есть
возможность да пойти что-то
дополнительно получить но на мой взгляд
это там порядка может быть 20 30
процентов нашего будущего в
экономическом смысле мне кажется это
меньше это меньше мне кажется в
экономическом смысле вот 1 но то стороны
склад pro second life мне красот
господин асад который разбирается в
психологии
подтвердит наверное это будет не
полностью как сказать консилмент нашу
жизнь это наверно будет такой как
предмет эскапизма потому что у людей
есть такая потребность в пути в
путешествие тоже с одной стороны тоже
эскапизм забыть проблемы вот
сегодняшнего дня до не надо делать
стирку лондре и так далее так далее то
же самое да вот я занимаюсь бизнесом для
меня играть в компьютерные игры это тоже
как бы одна из таких потребностей да как
там где поесть попить на вид играли там
другие какие-то вещи этого до развлекуха
да именно иски пизанская развлекуха так
что я мне про мозг отключается я вот в
этом правильном мире про меня как лось
еще ну то есть такие задатки да вот игра
была мафия 1 ма фи кунсей а вот там
потому что раньше были вот gt от 1 до
сверху человек видит не знаю что мы
доберемся до игр до новая можно варить
до 5 вот меня началось sanandres именно
вот после третьей версии сан андерс там
уже надо было своего героя прокачивать
он начал голодать есть он но конечно мы
коды прописывали чтобы он никогда не был
голодный себя zorgee.ru спасибо
все же вся чуть-чуть вы прописали да кто
нибудь кто не прописывал все врут
до нужно было уже своих героев прокачать
потом появился 5 года и до сих пор люди
в него играют и покупать такие дорогущие
скины эта экономика есть да то есть для
владельцев до
этой игры тоже самое что world of
warcraft и так далее что это но очень
круто что мы уже волнуемся что вот там
можно было выбирать из трёх героев да
вот и уже в пятом я сейчас уже как бы
друзья там и так далее да prompt он
почти что полноценный мир где есть такая
как бы конвенция когда можно там
встречаться язык разговор о том
который такой достаточно универсальный
такой достаточно дает хороший
качественный скипидар
в понимании метавселенной вообще мета с
латинского переводится как за пределами
то есть это за пределами реальности то
есть наша реальность это вот где мы
находимся вот наша семья у наш город наш
мир а из такая виртуальная реальность да
это тоже чего не существует
из по сути для меня метавселенной то
обман большой обман этот иллюзия в
которой мы жить я буду сегодня будут
хейтерам
негатив щекам который дает ребят и там
по снам или тогда идем там пропасть ноги
если говорить о самом деле дети наши да
они поглощают информации они живут в
этом виртуальном мире уже без we are
очков они уже в социальности вида ее
родители у них паника каждый день ко мне
поступает запрос асхат что делать как
отучить ребенка от телефона как сделать
так чтобы он перестал играть ему
интересно школы ему ничего интересно он
живет там ответственно и из конго и
школа уходит на заставляет пока я дам
эти там в виртуальном мире . вот я думаю
что в будущем в виртуальном мире будет
все там будет ли школа там будет и
секции там у этой тренировки это все
будет в одной детской комнате у ребенка
и
если так вот на период смотреть я думаю
что
возможно это все опыт будет приводить к
разрушению института семьи то есть ли
тут семьи как таковой будет уже в нем не
будет необходимости для каждого человека
будет своя реальность своя там семья
свои путешествия каждый будет жить так
как он хочет иметь усилена даст ему все
что он хочет любые эмоции любые
развлечения любые путешествия
так как связан с чем связано как связана
разрешение с от семьи и мин selena ну
зачем ребенку допустим общаться с папой
или с мамой когда он может виртуально
полетай со суперменом где-нибудь в
облаках да и совершать какие-то подвиги
другое а также другая что же друга и
потому что
ты же тот а чего ты ждёшь от мамой ты
тоже обменяться permanent вишня а чего
же этот ребенок от мамой внимание заботы
я в глобальном плане не согласен но в
чем-то я согласен потому что вот когда я
много в школьное время играл в компьютер
и да я был очень сисенто мини мог подкат
подкатывать девушкам до мне хотелось
всегда вот быть таким вот матч именами
из фильма heach но
получается то есть а у детей это все
будет amplifier на настолько что они
будут настолько вот стеснительный
настоящей жизни сделать какой-то знаю
первый шаг девушки до что получается вот
этой интеракции между полами девушка
парень и девушка даже как бы одной из
ребят давайте продолжим сначала
свое мнение что такое метрах сели на
самом деле вот мы сейчас рассматриваем
эту вселенную первый момент это с точки
зрения геймификации второй момент с
точки зрения facebook avi арад а мы
гугла но если копнуть чуть глубже и чуть
дальше the meta вселенная это же про
молодое поколение то есть понятное дело
что мы сейчас можем его не принимать и
так далее но наши
извиняюсь но ваши дети они уже родились
с инстаграмом внутри то есть я его
например только в возрасте там 20 лет я
его только начал изучать что это такое
дети уже родились они уже в инстаграме
получается новое поколение которое
родиться она уже будет в этой
дополненной реальности она уже будет там
она уже будет там учиться она уже будет
там и те на уж будь там гулять она уже
будет там взаимодействовать здесь
метавселенной это достаточно сильно
глубокий вопрос почему потому что если
рассматривать с точки зрения
геймификации то да окей там сан-андреасе
ты покачал своего персонажа и так далее
но нет такого четкого взаимодействия
между друг другом почему потому что там
еще про революцию игр можно это все
сместить и так далее ну то есть в плане
вот в моем понимании мета вселенная это
что-то обиде я еще с новыми технологиями
в революции игр в революции социально
социальных сетей так далее потому что
это новый тип общение то есть иными
словами в метров силенд даже сейчас мы
можем прогуляться по одной из мер к
вселенной вот включить ноутбук
прогуляться по одной этой вселенной
сесть поиграть в казино сесть там скоро
будет уже там уже церкви строить там уже
строят и учебные центры то есть там уже
такой момент который он достаточно
сильно глубокий и если там старшее
поколение еще этого не понимает никак не
принимает то поколение младшая которым
18 лет 16 лет пятнадцать лет они уже там
полностью там продаются земли там строят
инфраструктуру там это такой глубокий
новый мир и вопрос we are a вопрос там
вот этих новых технологий это просто как
ты взял просто одел и пошел то есть это
не основополагающей основополагающие то
новое новый вид взаимодействия
новый тип взаимодействия когда в
принципе человек будет сидеть на своем
диване до взаимодействовать полностью с
компьютером там сливочками и так далее
заказывать пельмени пусть ему привозят
пельмени и он может там никого не видеть
он может даже эти пельмени есть мета
вселенной до получать от этого кайф и
так далее но мы сейчас видим только у
как бы глазами а же еще есть и звуком а
и же еще вкусовые качества которые так
или иначе придумаем то есть пройдет три
четыре года и научиться делать из
компьютера звук эти
вкусовые какие то рецепторы улучшения
вкусовых рецепторов так далее это просто
вопрос мозга то есть это вопрос обучения
можно и поэтому здесь метавселенной
достаточно глубокий вопрос с точки
зрения криптовалюта криптовалютный рынок
он просто помогает это помогает
взаимодействию и нефти помогает
взаимодействию между пользователями
между людьми
вот смотрите я смотрю у нас у всех
разное понимание не то вселенной я в
мета вселенную бижу
больше вообще если брать с точки зрения
определения эта вселенная это постоянно
действующие постоянно действующие
виртуальное пространство где люди
взаимодействуют друг
с техникой то есть интернет of tanks с
техникой посредством своего аватара то
есть физически же мы не можем себя
перенесли в мета вселенную метавселенной
обязательно подразумевается что ты
действуешь через своего аватара они
лично ты соответственно отсюда я вижу
какой момент вот смотрите дело в том что
мета вселенную я наблюдаю уже везде то
есть это же вопрос такой что куда
направлена твое внимание к когда откуда
я вот до того как будет цукерберг
сказал про эту вселенную и
переименование в мета я об этом не думал
как а мета вселенной я размышлял как
инвесторы я исходил из того что куда
текут деньги я как бизнесмены и место
куда текут деньги я по этому поводу даже
выступал на укр инвест клубе игру
смотрите основная задача инвестора это
следить куда утекает внимание аудитории
куда течет внимание аудитории туда течет
туда текут и деньги я смотрю вниманию
аудиторию ходит час на возобновляемые
источники на
виртуальную реальность на лифте на
окраине пту и тогда ли туда деньги тоже
уходит я когда начал смотреть и у меня
начал складываться определён такой пазл
вот смотрите почему заговорили о
метавселенной именно сейчас потому что
эта вселенная вообще все строится на
блокчейне на облучение соответственно
криптовалюта соответственно нефти это
все обеспечение технологии
обеспечивающие существование нету
вселенной и вот получается если взять
вокруг нас мы уже социальной сети по
сути тоже мета вселенные одних кусочки
метавселенной наши и гав-гав это уже тут
же часть мета вселенной смотрите мы уже
раньше взаимодействовали через сон и
раньше вообще помните за справками
бегали потом появились ционной это
другой вид взаимодействия сейчас новые
взаимодействия уже гигов ты заходишь там
берешь любые справки там уже ту же права
наносить не надо собой
погода сырая личность не надо носить то
есть от физического мира мы обходим все
мы переходим в цифровой мир или самый
логичный способ все эти
эти объекты цифрового объективного но
реального материального мира перевести в
блокчейн в толкин его ногти и так далее
мы все же к этому идем и на самом деле
это уже все есть каждый день вокруг нас
и я каждый день когда читаю что там что
происходит мета вселенных там какие то
бишь иные сделки продают землю вот тоже
в центре land сейчас происходит такая
смесь игр
блокчейна криптовалют лифте
бизнеса рекламы все все туда идет и на
самом деле меня это достаточно сильно
пугает я просто для затравки скажу вот
раз вы говорили по поводу
как может повлиять
семью на воспитание вот представьте
сидит пацан
он зашел под аватаром сейчас кстати
недавно никак не дам весной ко мне
приходили девчата дни они хотели сделать
с меня аватар в социальных сетях с меня
аватар у них целая легенда есть и качать
этого героя в социальных сетях и они
говорят ваш аватар будет зарабатывает
больше чем вы потому что игру почему он
же мой двойник производная ангар нет он
будет зарабатывать больше чем вы на
рекламе потому что рекламодатели не
бояться вашего оба аватара а вас бояться
потому что вы можете чего-нибудь ляпнуть
и получим вот такой хейт или чего не
политическая ляпнете а это не каком
рынка рекламодатели не надо греть а ваши
аватаром контролируемый поэтому аватара
и кстати сейчас
раскрутили девчонка знаменитая модель
есть есть в вашем мире фианитом она даже
у нее рекламные контракты с dior там с
крупными компаниями рост то есть большая
работа стоит меньше миллиона но
связь между физическим объектом она
точно есть то есть если вы все же что не
такое скажите ваше фото аватар то
глюкоза было так я на самом деле так
вначале берется известный человек к нему
делается аватаров потом этот язык с
аватаром взаимодействий потом а то вот
он начинает отрываться от него
отрывается отрывается отрывать в
какой-то момент все аватар живет уже
полность своей жизни это просто реально
человеке используется как ступень ракеты
и просто для разгона и аватара
разгоняюсь потом обнажила не сам по себе
живет все равно да то есть
ты используешь аватар чтобы получить
какой-то extend если ты же я не знаю
если вы там записали конечно какой-то
курс
онлайновый и читаете этот курс допустим
покаяться но или еще почему-то да и и
читайте его во множественных копиях не
знаем вот но миллиарде копит например да
каждому виду альным человеку например ну
окей да тогда он живет словно сам по
себе в котором какой-то период но связь
с физическим объектом будет если завтра
нам физический объект завелась что то
нехорошее я очень сомневаюсь что кто-то
захочет
на тех же условиях контактировать с
аватаром не смотрите сейчас же есть
аватару уже на минуту и голевую сетки
актеров которые умерли это не есть
правда то есть они уже ничего плохого
точно так же все понятно из того же за
аватаром сидит команда которая же для
которой это является бизнесом давайте
вернемся к мета вселенной все такие вот
смотрите по эта вселенная все-таки
считаю вот на стороне асхата в этом
плане что мораль точно может пошатнуться
потому что синек пацан он взял себя в
отара мощного амбала да во первых мета
вселенной ты можешь аватара взять
мальчика девочку ты можешь сидеть взять
аватара старуху да а ты мужик здоровый
вот такой мальчик возьмет аватара
здорового амбала да какая девушка
возьмет аватара пацана да какие сейчас
же и то есть и вот в том-то и дело вот в
метро вселенной и он ведет себя мальчик
ведет себя как здорово амбал но
психологии у него мальчика он может по
ходу дать под старику по морде женщин
утонуть этой дыры потому что для его тех
моральных принципов еще нету другие люди
смотрят что там происходит и это же
потом транслируется на нашу реальную
жизнь поэтому vysotsky каламазу ребенка
если он уже не понимает кто у нас
аномальный тебя сейчас происходит то
есть и дальше этого будет еще больше ну
это же вопрос и вообще почему чтобы вот
я согласен что это вопрос воспитания то
есть если мы на каком-то этапе понимаем
под вопрос что делать с детьми
чтобы там ограничить влияние ну сейчас
слава богу все гаджеты позволяет очень
четко ограничивать там любое влияние
есть управления экранным временем свой
личный кейс у меня у детей четко в день
у них есть на игру в обычный день 1
минута то есть там лучше ставить одну
минуту то минимальное ограничение на
игру на прямо он все игры заблокируется
через одну минуту ровно использовать
задние то есть посчитай нет возможности
играть выиграть среди в рабочие дни до
чтобы хотим чтобы они общаясь с реальным
а выходные бисах какой-то extinction
побольше то есть на самом деле вещь
такая абсолюта подконтрольно я уверен
что краз контент мента вселенной он
гораздо более подконтрольно может быть
чем
контент в реальном мире что в реальном
мире это может быть неподконтрольна я
уверен что там будет целая большая
работа проведена
с точки зрения там регулирования и так
далее да как государственное еще
какого-то
вот поэтому это будет такие папы как ты
рамиль прокачайте айтишники никуда
остальным показан этом
раб и корабль а 19 максимум так и сейчас
же это мой это сейчас то же самое
история происходит ты можешь забить на
ребенку он там будет не пойми с кем
общаться с там с пацанами за гаражами
курить траву или что не течет нам пить
не знаю сама же может быть живом мире
нет нет это это я считаю вот то что
сейчас виртуален происходит это гораздо
опаснее вас не потому что тогда ты не
понимаешь а не работать на психику то
жалко га но на бухнул подтянут все
считается там ты знаешь чего произойдет
и
проспится утром ты его ремня вот христа
и живот и всех делов то но здесь реально
вот кричат же куча виртуальных вещей ты
мне там типа синего кита
суицида детей и тогда когда дует нашими
детьми реально управляет новенькие
приятного исследовать и разблокировки я
честно говоря из своего окружения слышу
второй раз только вот от тебя и у меня
ещё один не знакомы которую все за
регулировал все заблокировал и так далее
5 минут работы потому что сам в детстве
сидел на сайтах когда интернет только
появился наши родители же не знали как
это все одни не стре ровать нам поэтому
мы в свое детство там не знаю раньше
времени может быть увидели какие-то да
там сайты вот скотина вконтакте
порнографии кстати очень много и вот он
потащит доступ просто как бы не
ограничены большая проблема что родители
не умеет администрируйте это и хорошо да
вот у меня моему сыну пока два года до
но там лет 10 бойда я буду знать вот как
рамиль да я буду прокачены так далее но
вдруг появится очень какая-то такая
новая плоскость где мы уже будем
устаревшие пердуны где дети будут строки
будет тогда появляется
больше мы пытаемся контролировать тем
больше дети будут находить способы чтобы
обойти во сколько ребенку лет раме 8 лет
вот 90 то скажет папочка как бы либо
скажи ты мне давай не контролирует либо
сказка всё на 12 лет я муж но здесь она
станет второй телефон который уличные а
это для папы надо его попал все хорошо я
общаясь 5 минут в день только до в
телефоне а здесь у меня будет сутками
зависать или сбу своя жизнь и ты был
думать я как хороший папа я контролирую
у меня всё под контролем у меня как бы
все схвачено соглашусь а в этом поэтому
воспитание детей ты говоришь главное
воспитание это все важно но давайте
разберём слова воспитания это в ось
питания представьте что у ребенка есть
такой юсб выход и туда идет питание либо
это питание идет от родителей и родители
передают свои ценности и принципы
моральные до либо это питание идет с
интернета где отсутствуют какие-то нормы
морали ограничения на какие-то принципы
и вопрос от кого больше питания получает
современный ребенок от родителей
общается слушать или же от интернета от
социальных сетей фильмов нет секса ютюба
и так далее но ведь родители наши более
воспитывать интернете скажу конкретно
мультики и фильмы сериалы оттуда
получается больше воспитание каждого
ленивых родителей да есть такой а мы не
такие и есть такой
есть такое понятие называется верта
вертолет ли радио да есть такое понятие
вертолетный родитель вообще его
придумали но относительно все другой
плоскости короче в америке сделали
исследование что почему то есть дети в
америке скажи мне развивать а также
хорошо как скажем там нельзя в европе до
оказывается их детские площадки слишком
безопасные и то есть там нету элемент
контролируемого риска и так далее да и 1
1 британка еще во время вот войны когда
в здании было покупатель до увидела что
дети не играют на и на игровых площадках
они играют на вот там где мина
взорвалась да то есть там где есть
гвозди молотки и так далее и так далее
поэтому
больше экшна пруда мы сейчас говорим что
вот у нас все больше и больше родителей
вертолетные родители поставили включили
телек вот что за родители да то есть они
сами виноваты что дети получаются стали
зомби да скажем такие более продвинутые
прокачанные не знаю как как их лучше
назвать элитные до родители дают скажем
давайте для оптимизма назовем что это 10
процентов мне кажется это те самые будут
и родителей которые ну то есть оторвут
детей от вот этого
слишком безопасных детских площадок с
резиновым настилом где травмы невозможно
просто загнал и забор да а будут такие
настоящие которые ng где есть вот
интерактивное взаимодействие
родителя с ребенком то есть процесс как
бы познание мира она будет происходить
как бы вместе с другой стороны смотреть
сейчас же вот никуда не спрячешься дети
вот вот эти маленькие да а вот когда
10-12 лет переходный возраст они уже
хотят тоже но space это личную
территорию и кстати вы не должны
нарушать их личную территорию давать
свободу и они хотят стать взрослыми
соответственно что обязательно у них
найдутся сверстники которые помогут
подскажет как там что-то взломать
джейлбрейк ментами еще хакнуть и так
далее либо телефон для папы контроль на
телефон а вот и свой телефон то есть от
виртуального пространства и игр
вот это вселенных никуда не деться
по-любому вот мы пробовали делать
эксперимент забирать у детей телефоны но
у них домашка приходит на телефон
тесты приходит на телефон
расписание на телефон
спасибо джеку мо который сказал лень
двигатель прогресса
пуповину не оторвать то есть дети уже
вообще инфраструктурное и государства и
общества и образования на нас
привязывает к ребенка к телефону уже
привязывать уже выросла школу ходит ему
надо нужно иметь телефон каждая
технология она несет какие-то
какие-то риски какую-то опасность надо
же я просто осознать ее управляться мне
кажется польза гораздо больше за то что
теперь будет доступна там тем же детям
про стойки есть допустим сегодня меня
ребенок приходит и говорит ну правда
приболела на горло болит и
и не поведешь в школу например но
принципе наверное если бы была не та
школа то почему мне то есть ласкает там
есть бар тур большой нет пожалуйста
можешь то есть вариантов возможности
много никто же не говорит о том что ты
не должен как отец там сидеть как мать
там время проводить проводи время
воспитывает общайся и все будет о'кей не
будешь это делать так это и раньше была
та же самая история кто-то вам ягуры там
загружаем и что
j нюхает том что это дело еще родители
говори пусть лучше со мной типа в первый
раз попробуй чем с пацанами там где лишь
такие родители
я думаю знаете на самом деле
все же реагирует вот вы сказали допустим
группа тоже самый там синий кит я помню
сам переживал
за короче сестренку мамой
дальнейших руки до когда эта вся история
пошла и мы зашли в ее в вконтакте
увидишься на вот в этой группе сидит ну
подписываем такие голову боже но потом
стали разговорит да ну как бы нет
слишком далеко все было но
приходит какое-то регулирование начинает
группы где-то закрывать начинает
контролировать в любом случае в
интернете еще вопрос тоже как это метро
селена конца будет построена то есть
если она же будет такой коннектор дата
все друг с другом связаны я думаю что
там будет вполне себе точно то будет
какое-то регулирование точно будет
регулирование то есть наверняка там
будет свои ники правило закон это как
там вебстор ты условно говоря приложение
может быть в appstore с вирусом возможно
здесь будет какие-то практики
влияние на возраст который обмануть
наверное чем дальше тем тяжелее будет
поэтому я думаю что в долгу все бы
хорошо но проблемы будут будут и
смертельные случаи будет и какие там я
не знаю там суициды с этим связаны
проблемы будут точно но
плюс мне кажется раз больше можно да не
скажу с позиций вообще всего этого ладно
оставим наверно тему детей
пора ли и покрыт
смотрите вообще само понятие мета
вселенной в первую очередь создана с
позиции демократии то есть с позиции
децентрализованных автономных
организаций как сейчас это пошло когда
за любое новое обновление либо за любую
новую технологию за любое новое какое-то
внесение даже в изменении в проект
голосуйте пользователей которые имеют на
это право то есть так она и называется и
за и это сейчас тренд в криптовалютными
это децентрализованной автономной
организацией то есть это оля демократии
и в первую очередь
метавселенной который сейчас существуют
они в 1 в 1 что они делают они connected
людей людей очень быстро потому что
человек бразилии образно говоря может из
черенка загс казахстана посетить одну
метавселенную там пообщаться образно
говоря не имеет если у кого-то
заблокирован facebook the mall другого
заблокирован в контакте образно говоря
первый момент второй момент с позиции
демократического общества из позиции
расчета вообще криптовалютный рынок был
создан только потому что никто не хотел
терпеть не могу
гегемонию определенных государств
возьмем так и поэтому что получилось
появилась децентрализация чтобы не было
1 1 1 платежное средство чтобы не было
сформировано в руках одной стороны руках
одного человека одной организации
автономность хотя автор хотя по поводу
автономности и по поводу анонимности
смесь хотел сказать здесь еще можно
поспорить потому что не все криптовалюты
анонимные большинство из них уже не
анонимны тоже как сам bitcoin его можно
отслеживать смело просто непонятно кто
не владеет то есть я могу показать
адреса владеющих там 100 миллиардами
долларов но мы не знаем просто кто это
что это за человек и так далее поэтому
здесь
самок сам по себе тренд развития
метавселенной он интересен тем что я
говорю то есть позиция взаимодействие
людей она лучше и позиция именно
демократического общества то есть
создание той самой демократии которые
люди хотят увидеть и если здесь вот
позицию с точки зрения аватара да то что
вы там говорили
про то что аватар там рекламщикам будет
удобно чтобы аватар там типа говорил то
же самое это но я скажу наоборот то есть
я буду в бета вселенная буду сам
выбирать за что я хочу то есть что что
мне показывать какую рекламу не
показывать это даже сейчас уже
реализовано в браузер brace если можно
посмотреть то есть когда я получаю
деньги их токены за то что я смотрю вот
эту рекламу я не смотрю например вот эту
рекламу то есть иными словами это и вот
rival эволюцию вот этой вот всего
развитие когда я сам выбираю что я хочу
говорю я сам выбираю с кем я хочу
контракт заключаю так далее они
рекламщики подходят ко мне и говорят так
ты сегодня будешь вот это говорит мне я
считаю что это все пойдет с позиции того
что каждый человек каждый пользователь
будет выбирать то что он сам хочет но с
другой стороны же
все равно же место вселенной больше
возможность отслеживать полностью твое
поведение и все твои покупки движения
когда сейчас делают это делает
контекстной рекламы
реклама все построенная мне royal club
известно при royal club купила банды
гулко в грузии но контекстную рекламу
таргетируя рекламу никто не отменял это
сейчас делается но там метров селена это
будет вообще все понятно давайте сейчас
поговорим о свойственное здесь можно
скажу а вот с другой стороны когда мы
подключаемся к нынешним мета вселенной
не видно кто мы и что мы видим только
нас наш адрес кошелька то есть мы
подключаем просто свой адрес кошелька но
в адресе кошелька не написано что я
константин не столько лет я оттуда то
это просто уникальный мой адресу все я
создал себе аватар чека какого я хочу я
пошел и прикреплен только мой ник но и
только мой никнейм и мой адрес на
который я могу принимать вот в этом не
проблема вот рамиль говорит что рано или
поздно это будет отрегулирована я
например стороны того что отрегулирован
они не будет потому что этих это все
лимита вселенных на самом деле много
плюс еще даркнет есть там своими это
вселенные могут появиться это будет а
плюс смотри если аватары в социальных
сетях мы можем делать аватара они как-то
привязаны там через айпи адрес через еще
учета наши полиция всегда может поймать
нас заставит извиниться на камеру то
метавселенной там номер кошелька
соответственно крипто кошелька
соответственно там человек творить может
действительно все что хочет но ребята
уже может потому что и сейчас это тоже
не куто'пи люди на самом деле кому надо
они понимают
чтобы кошельку получить доступ ты все
равно получаешь ему доступ если еще надо
будет четко можно будет понять у кого
лишь на уровне что там человека это есть
на то есть сейчас я очень сомневаюсь в
том что
ну скажем так
да природных рамок то есть конечно если
ты очень хочешь зайти в даркнет ты
сделаешь это да но
там
99 98 процентов кейсов защитить можно
кто хочет он найдет точно 30 можно
любого да конечно эти основатели bitcoin
и как вызовут что то что на кому-то
сатоши накамото его ищет весь мир
разъем кто
вас никто сверху вообще
99 процентов он определён поэтому
либо это просто сообщество разработчиков
и все сатоши накамото это просто
уникальный никнейм в свитере человека
который создал на рынке и все вопрос при
регуляцию он один вопрос регуляция будет
демократическая регуляция будет
пользователями то есть уже есть
регуляции в дицентра ленин описано типа
ты не можешь там сказать то ты не можешь
сказать это и так далее ребята если мы
говорим про генерального вот скажем так
будет некое общее вот как есть общий
интернет убираем доклада есть общий
интернет вот речь про общем эта
вселенную она будет невероятно
зарегулированная почти уверен да то есть
если ты хочешь без всяких услаждения
зайти вот эту самую second life купил
нашего мира с каким-то extends нами где
как раз таки и будет львиная часть
экономики все остальное от будет думаю
она будет очень сильно зарегулированы
если ты хочешь уйти в какие-то отдельные
там части это наверное не будет огромной
проблемой хотя опять же следы ты все
равно будешь составляет так иначе тебе
очень нужно будет найти тебя найдут но
да такое но это сейчас есть опять же это
и мне кажется это было всегда так и
иначе ну это было всегда ну чтобы вы
понимали arcnet овский bitcoin он
отслеживается интерполу то есть есть
dark дедовский bitcoin который при
переводе например на аккаунт любой из
централизованных бирж которые
регулируются кем-либо то есть тем же
самым войны на санта обе так далее
происходит сразу блокировка аккаунт и
связи с тем что чтобы нам
зарегистрироваться там нам нужно указать
свои данные к нам сразу приеду то есть
это ну этот это этот момент уже работает
именно dark ни тоски то есть грязь это
так называемый грязный bitcoin это
криптовалюта когда использована для
оплаты терроризма давайте
обсудим вот если рассматривать
метавселенную пользу и вред да вот
давайте обсудим обсуждать позже мета
вселенной
попытаемся на позитиве по поговорить вот
метро вселенная и работа эта вселенная
работа вот я просто перед этим подкастом
тоже прочитал несколько статей по поводу
того что даже крупные корпорации заходят
туда и сандерленд там coca-cola там гучи
магазин открыл более того сейчас активно
идет продажа виртуально одежды раньше
одно так виртуальной одежда это то что в
игре ты заходишь типа как форд найти или
там world of tank skin не покупаешь и
вот это да на своём раскинув купили в
роста к на какой самого скинов купили
world of tanks виза на 57 тысяч долларов
и носки на да но и то бишь но у них одно
мика так вот смотри так щас пошли уже
скины для зум конференций вот в россии я
читал статистику в двадцатом году
продажи одежды в марте-апреле упали на
90 процентов по сравнению с февралем
потому что люди в халате ходят заходит
это один ольга лсд рубашку в зубе там
дальше в пижаме сидят так вот чтобы вот
эту часть убрать сейчас по и очень много
модных домов начали выпускать пиксельную
одежду специально для зум конференции я
могу одеть красивые пиджак от кучей но
не на себя она изображение которое в
зуме и ты будешь видеть меня в красивый
бутик это еще было реализовано фотошопе
когда надо было там сделать фотографии 3
на 4 ты приходишь обычный
marketplace это воды
и там не было фасилитации marketplace а
вот это да там можно было самому
сейчас все же дело в том что вот
смотрите бренды переходят туда я еще
заметил такую вещь вот эта вселенная на
что самое интересное что наши моральные
принципы они не мигрируют метавселенную
там наоборот больше всего звуками себя а
имущественное расслоение она мигрирует
то есть вот у меня недавно племянник и
играл в одну игру она называется том я
император он говорит там пришел один
корейский игрок у него фиолетовый халат
халат за миллион 600 тысяч долларов
1600000 долларов а где ты откуда знала
что цена этого халатами до 600 тыс
долларов а в этой игре официально ценник
идет там они на аукционе продают этих
вещей торец
до 600000 долларов и он пришел бедна
игру в этом халате в игре то сего играли
настоящего его только что нет
виртуальный халатно
живешь из сотни или вот coca-cola при
синдроме правило вечеринку собрала 2 2
тысячи человек собрались там на
вечеринке она подняла пятьсот семьдесят
пять тысяч долларов реальных долларов за
одну вечеринку она построила в dice
интернет здание в виде банки кока-колы и
там наверху лифты вот где горлышко и они
там наверху тусовались все виртуальные я
вам расскажу историю парень и 22 лет
здесь живущий в вал мотив в казахстане
создал и на птичке из пяти тысяч роботов
взял 2 индусов 1 колумбийца который над
ними шествовал про этот создал mind из
роботов причем реально красивых роботов
и пошел не на казанский рынок он пошел
на рынок америки он создал twitter начал
его рекламировать и за 3 месяца он
продал на полмиллиона долларов в том что
даже полторы тысячи expand для для
простых чайников как я что он сделал
робот
создал один плане лада зал виртуальных
роботов у некрасивые чем он создал
tutorial в котором показал что вот это
вот рука правая она есть только у трех
роботов из 5 тыс а вот это вот кепка
есть там с 2 робота виртуальный срок это
хорошо эта тема ну как бы тренда хайпа и
так далее но вообще сам смысл нефти вот
вы говорите вы покупали скины world of
tanks и например в эволюции гейминга вы
будете у кого-то из нас к примеру
покупать те же самые танки ну то есть
скины и танков и зарабатывать буду я то
есть как это как пользователь которую
которую вам продал это а компания будет
всего забирать там 10 процентов своих
отступных комиссии так далее потому что
сейчас все наоборот потому что сейчас мы
например хотим купить скин выплатим
разрабам мы платим разработчика поэтому
не интересно вот самая популярная игра
акс infinite которая стрельна вас в июне
в июле месяце и и криптовалюта
стрельнула на рекордной там 108 многое
псов волочет почему просто потому что
индонезийцы и сели и начали играть чем
больше ты играешь тем больше очков
зарабатывать чем больше ты бери продаёшь
эти скины эти карточки энергичные ты
зарабатываешь и они зарабатывали выше
чем среднестатистический человек в
индонезию более того я взялся
подтверждение скажу я сейчас я как раз
рассматриваю вопросы инвестирования в
компанию
называется
гейн хотел как отельные и гордо где
игроки
майнят толкин и благодаря своим играм то
что они там играют тем больше они там
играют тем больше толкина монет больше
полкам то они на этом зарабатывают то
есть это появилось целое рабочие места
играть в игру это рабочее место которое
генерит тебе ночь его диктатором и и
огромное количество всяких
сканов и извиняюсь за выражение до
который там из 100 проектов если опять
выстрелит это будет реально классное
выставит хорошо анализа рынке много
легких денег много дешевых денег во
первых это все благодаря к виду в первую
очередь благодаря очень сильно по
тренду криптовалютного рынка поэтому
огромное количество компаний я их просто
ну вот моя основная задача это
анализировать их поэтому я смотрю на всю
эту индустрию и понимаю что да выстрелит
там пять из 100 выстрелов сильно хорошо
остальные 95 созданы просто для того
чтобы собрать ваши деньги причем люди
вот так вот стоят мне говорят
нет она там на тайм-сквер и рекламы и
tychy бы было это низком ребят ну это
как бы технологического прогресса в этой
монете нет никакой также в игровой
индустрии сейчас в целом же конце тем
целом если брать криптовалюты там
понятно что они вообще в целом все под
вопросом точки точки зрения добавленной
стоимости какой-либо я бы даже сказал
мое личное мнение там на добычу ты же
биткойнов уходит атомное количество
энергии и я считаю что это больший вред
чем польза но хотя сам bitcoin
фирму
накануне станут снять пену
haipai skype в обществе так как и деньги
переходят туда теперь вопрос еще такой
момент здесь возникает из-за то что весь
х и бyдет сторону это вселенные
криптовалюты нефти тут и так далее наши
дети тоже и дороге они понимают что
профессии будущего там то не хочешь быть
садоводам никто не хочет
быть дворником мое место и танками духе
мне кажется это не принципиально новые
профессии прощения то есть по большому
счету да это профессия там я не знаю
предпринимателя дизайнера однозначно
работа архитектора
архитектора
разработал пера и гранатом копирайтера
да ну по большому счету наверное она и в
целом вот
вы сказали ты должен быть чем-то очень
крут у тебя должен быть либо бренд очень
сильный или целом должен быть чем-то
очень круто я не знаю там какой
то скорее всего
все будет забирать лучшие а если ты там
учитель номер 1000 по там русскому языку
или по казахскому языку скорее всего ты
будешь очень беден но тем ни менее
учитель номер 1000 по русскому языку на
сегодняшний день может стать учителем
номер один по русскому языку в мета
вселенной если на получается самый
первый туда зайдет эта тема социального
статуса
чем социального статуса я думаю
фундаментально это все равно это это же
базовый скилл да то есть он согласен что
кто пойдет раньше может лучше может
обратить понять да может
другой стороны смотрите здесь еще таком
нами
как вот я еще одну тему хочу затронуть
как в мета вселенная будет формироваться
личный бренд вот как он будет формат
сидел на жизни понятно мы общаемся у нас
появляется определенная репутация да мы
достигаем каких-то достижений бизнес и в
оффлайн бизнес и потом про нас печатают
газеты журналы java нас узнают как to
bring формируется мета вселенной ты
делаешь бизнес как там формировать
личным приятных и чудо шнуром но как
указав христа к выражение а там шеф
пассажир те да то есть сейчас чтоб
потому что сейчас входа на рынок и про
инстаграм уже настолько сложной да вот
например то 15 16 м году можно было там
вот здесь заката себя сфотографирует
какие-то два умных слова написать да и
уже что-то да сейчас но не знаю по
формату или нет ну то есть девушки
показывать какие-то на 100 и часть
[смех]
настолько доходит до такого уже
уровня когда уже все настолько на
дрожжах и то есть ставки настолько
высоки что мне кажется она тоже самое
здесь люди будут когда это уже настолько
достигнет того что там условно 80
процентов населения человек земли будет
там то там уже нужно будет ну то есть
какие-то экстраординарные вещи нужно там
творить из этом раздеть его аватара
перед тем показать свои и развернуть и
кто уже решает да то есть мне кажется
наоборот этот алгоритм который меняет
социальные сети и во многом заставляет
по-другому смотрите по демократизации в
том что ты можешь стать суперзвездой с
первого ролика будучи ноунеймом потому
что алгоритм ну грубо говоря показывает
и тоже начали дает равне возможно я
думаю это вообще в целом фишка tic-taca
и возможно самая справедливая модель
создание как бы действительно крутого
контента никакого контента за которым
просто это однажды прославленный бренд а
действительно круто vacant а вот чтобы
через 10 лет тур но там будет уже как в
как более раскрученные игроки рынка как
вот этот парень кобидо например в те кто
китай да да да думаю что практика
возможности пацаны появится сам алгоритм
дает возможность любому всегда то есть
конечно если кто-то система делает
какое-то каком месте да если он забил бы
всего лишь один классный гол он может
быть и появился бы где инстикт оки потом
супер там просмотром количество да но
если он системно круто играет у нее
действительно появляется большое
количество подписчиков но при этом
каждый каждое каждый конкретное действие
мы все так или иначе все равно под
микроскопом рассматривается с нуля
каждый раз не ну по крайне мере вот эти
кого хочет нравиться теперь а вот опять
и то и другое будет сочетать другой
смотреть мираж в этом плане тоже прав в
каком плане если мы бра возьмем
трафик то стоимость трафика за последние
семь лет выросло в десять раз то есть
сейчас с каждым годом даже в в сети в
этом в каждым годом к даже за сутки
закупка рекламы вот даже просто ты
покупаешь рекламу за последние семь лет
стоимость рекламы размещение рекламы в
10 раз выросла то есть как а самый
критичный cost это растет вот так почему
и он будет расти больше поршень крепком
от больше интернет бизнеса втб и такое
же давление происходит на социальные
сети социальных сетях больше больше к
лицу где больше появляться крейцеров
больше криттеров каждый хочется создать
свое имя каждый хочет большое колич
подписчиков и начинается уже такое
разнообразие что
на братья подписчиков очень сложно
реклама становится очень дорогой и вот
здесь форс-мажора 2 . то что он не раз
говорит это
как это называется преимущество первого
хода она имеет место быть и не в этом
плане но по социальным сетям еще более
менее понятно а вот помета вселенной я
думал вот представьте куча людей сидят с
рождению не с рождения с 20 лет или счас
какие там делают бизнес они вообще в
оффлайне когда бизнес не делай вот как
им создавать бренды там но смотрите
классно же будет когда
например 20-летний студент идёт помета
вселенной да и у него огромными большими
буквами написано кайден
интересно ну-ка дай-ка зайду заходит а
там мормонт зале вич на том языке на
котором он туда заходит он транслирует
идеологию и окей там без десяти человек
там ладно пусть 3 например зайдут
останутся и посмотрят 15 20 минут ваше
идеология примеру и это же для вас плюс
у меня понятно не у меня у меня уже в
планах весят другие например а другие
будут просто стримить ну например вот
так
за молодого человека у которую чен ун и
вот ему как выстрелит
лёха ты
сделать что-то крутое ты в первый день
заберешь для artpro смотреть сериал
беком mirrors .
есть сериал бэк мир знает да там вот
здесь 1 серия да где короче они собирают
свои звездочки там и одна девушка короче
она там стремилась там 49 да и там что
то там натворили замеры фокус да да да
да и даже мне кажется когда такая
произойдет saturation и даже те кто ко
мне кажется сюр но будет ну и в мета
вверх примерном их тех уму и наверно
придем что у нас будет там не знаю как у
военных там чины погоны у нас будут но
таким образом все потихоньку идет к к
тому кто китайской моделей когда есть
социальные рэнкинги
во-первых смотрите пол днем установили
они к другой стороны установили
максимальное количество камер на душу
населения в горам во всех городах эти
все камеры компаниях как нежин дополним
анапа она подключена к единой системе то
есть человек по улице идет его по лицу
по походке растут он уже не сетчатки
глаз же по походке по по лицу по
поведению распознавать человека сразу на
нём покажется его социальный номер
сколько налогов платил кому он должен им
алименты не элементы задолженность то
все мысли у нас это только часть то что
не выпускают за границу сетей
задолженности а у них про человека все
известно и вот у человека уже статус
соответственно тем ниже статус человека
тебе шанс не получить работу давида тем
меньше у него зарплата даже если он
получил работу и получается мы идем ко
мне тоже социальным расслабленно
расстоянию а уже касты появятся
человечески касты как
вечер поэтому бета вселенная будет
возможность
это же все будет доработана мы просто
сейчас видим вот в таком моменте
получилось как игры которые начали
разрабатывать с точки зрения ногтей они
там выходят самым фигурам качеству то же
самое сейчас как мета вселенной выходит
в сауну в качестве 90-х годов как игры
сейчас вышли в девяностом world of
warcraft сейчас по качеству намного
лучше чем любая метавселенная которой
есть но это же вопрос просто эволюции то
есть мы подождем 5 лет и через пять лет
действительно будет классно это будет
как вот вживую как будто мы здесь сидим
будет все тоже самое только то по факту
я одену очки я буду сидеть дома
мы будем находиться где-нибудь в
каком-нибудь какой-нибудь той же самой
студии только не в реальном мире
каждый дом или где ему угодно и все мы
хотим и уже там находится
это более глубокий момент матрицы выхода
этой тогда это наверное не ваш своего
ребенка аркетт иконами всегда попадались
это вселенной придумали это снова
преуспевшие кто-то не преуспевшие но это
не проблема в том что а демократия будет
больше котикам экономии там же за счет
свободного движения капитала вверх-вниз
защита 1 га на наследство все-таки
делать так что семьи богатые семьи ракер
уют но в технологической сферы в мета
вселенных тот предстоит предстать тот
человек который сидит там где-то там
ближе к алгоритму до
представь вот же его никак не смыслишь
оттуда или кто больше часов провел он
там навечно вот он создал это в себе
прообраз цукерберг вот цукерберга вот он
там не то что ну да он создал мы просто
люди нахлынут туда фейсбук будет уже
является с авторами фейсбука потому что
без людей не было бы фейсбук но теперь
фейсбук юрий дуров телеграме берет когда
она ему нужна любое сообщение нам
присылают и мы все denim вот его
сообщение заметили до пробивает все
пожалуй тоже рекламные это же
тестирование рекламы да это было
тестирование а до этого он присылал а
когда там про навального там еще учета
был он прям прессовал или ты хочешь не
хочешь и ты читаешь и у может заставить
пока ты не прочтешь ты не можешь это не
надо съесть это сейчас есть вот я к там
надо вы смогли это же мета вселенные
создаются они создаются кем-то и уровня
фильтр путин тоже может что нет кто то у
всех появится в телевизорах что-нибудь
давайте
мы вы хотите но у старого стиля я
понимаю что мы у нас бумага тем для
обсуждения очень много и наверно мы
замахнулись на слишком большую тему
сегодня но мы как бы все по чуть по
чуть-чуть поцарапали поцарапали давайте
поговорим на такую вещь
у нас не так много времени осталось кто
как видит
себя мета вселенной или свое будущее или
как о хотел бы чтобы было чтобы
выглядело метавселенной вот ты сейчас
говорил что я сижу пиццу мне приносит
или еще чуть вот давай из этого концерна
если мы начнем с этого конца это не мое
желание какое-то но это я говорю здесь
может быть такой вариант развития
событий там через десять лет когда я
просто буду сидеть не я а кто нибудь да
допустим мне не к человеку не важно
будет как он выглядит как он одетую
сколько он весит и так далее и тому
подобное в реальными в рио в реальности
хотя это еще большой вопрос в реальности
ли мы или нет
вот и
будет находиться в определенной мета
вселенной в обширной мета вселенной не в
той который мы сейчас привыкли видеть да
там сам бог сидит ровно так далее и даже
не фейсбук другое что-то крупное и до
его задача будет основная то есть эта
задача покушать ну то есть в реальном
мире это поесть и так далее а вся его
жизнь все весь его социальный статус вся
его система обучения и так далее и тому
подобное она будет все его скиллы они
будут там конечно в это тяжело поверить
сейчас потому что мы думаем о том что
это будет долго это будет лет 20 и так
далее но если вот так вот поразмыслить
туда через 10 15 лет может быть такой
опять-таки опять-таки не все же так не
все же что это может быстрее вы
посмотрите и гав уже ваша цифра является
юридическая ваша цифровая личность
ноготь должен казахстан это вселенной
уже по сути в это всегда то есть все
ваши документы всего право собственности
недвижимости машины все там
это благодаря нашей стране то есть нашей
стороны одни одна из лучших цифровизация
на самом деле та вселенная вот оно это
никаких доз 15 лет ключевое отличие
умеет усилена вами татьяна и тоже вот
эти все данные хранятся у всех а у нас
она пока вы сегодня сюда
это было голода и
это каждый хранить там где он хочет
хранить то есть она книжка в которой
есть там я извиняюсь это говорю до н.э.
птичка в которой есть там моя одежда как
у аватара мой там скилл мы там этот он
будет храниться у меня у меня на
кошельке у меня была пицца в блокчейне в
принципе у меня вот здесь здесь большой
конфликт между государствами и метро
всегда огласим да потому что государство
хочет данной храните себя конечно амита
в себе на это 10 10 зон также кроме
конкретно контролировать 51 бразилии то
биткойны и это в какой-то миг может
вызвать определенный конфликт между
властями как сет происходит конфликт
между фиатами когда валютами
им непонятно чем это закончится хотя
технология блокчейн все признают что-то
крутая технология и государство
придумывает и так далее царство повезло
но это вопрос кто
рамиль считает государыня
расскажет и как видишь эту вселенную и
вообще как бы ты хотел видеть какую оно
должно 1 как я хотел бы наверное видите
то чтобы крупнейшие игроки на рынке
наверно это корпорации как вот фэйсбук
да там илон маск айран скоро
подключиться чтоб они договорились и
поставить какие-то ограничения на
времяпровождения в этом виртуальном мире
потому что у человека нет тормозов
голове до эмоции
чтобы люди
рассудили потому что когда камень
родители говорят асад как отучить
ребенка телефона я говорю с карт скрыть
или как отучить вас от телефона и тогда
скажу как ребенка отучить потому что
родители сами зависают там и не у детей
не у родители нет тормозов колыме мы все
мы мы теряем контроль над мы туда
погружаемся но скорее всего мало кто из
корпорации сделать ограничение наоборот
их задача как бизнеса создавать много
больше это противоречит бизнесу да к
чему вот мой прогноз к чему приведет
вообще развитие мета вселенных
перспективе там 10 50-100 лет скорее
всего то придет тому что население будет
уменьшаться и это парить придет приведет
концу человечество объясню почему сейчас
есть такие тенденции до мировые что
люди не хотят создавать семьи
европа она уже всё не рожает детей и в
европ идет на вымирание сейчас идет
тренд однополых браков однополые браки
когда мужчины с мужчинами женщины
женщинами и я думаю единственный
сдерживающий фактор всего населения
планеты что их сдерживать этих туда в
однополые браки это от отсутствие
возможности заводить потомство мы как бы
два мужчины для женщины они не могут
завести потомство
как бы биологии все пока нет эко но
но опять же не так силен и даст
возможность
этим семьям 40 создавать виртуального
ребенка вот это точно это как у нас
то есть у таких семей
мы же на все этап появится больше
однополых семей потому что появится
возможность заводить детей причем как не
говорят родители был бы путь чтобы так
вот ребенка тактик на паузу поставить и
что звук выключен это возможно появится
вот и все ты снял очки и все твой у
ребенка нет ты отдыхаешь ты делаешь ты
хочешь соскучился одел очки вот ребенок
мамочка пойдем поиграем это первый этап
второй этап я считаю что в принципе
упраздниться институт семьи и люди
подумают а нафига мне жениться и
выходить замуж терпеть какого-то этого
человека подало родственники там до фото
для кого-то делать подстраиваться я
создан виртуальный аватар своего свои
идеальные женщины по параметрам по
внешности по характеру по поведению да и
и все
я буду работа зарабатывать деньги и
оплачивать интернет и возможность
апгрейдить свой аватар да и у меня вечно
молодая красивая жена а у женщины вечно
красавчики наиболее тем более сейчас
кстати фейсбук до начала тестировать
костюмы где передаются все ощущения мета
костюмы но фейсбук начал тестировать то
есть одеваешь костюм и и он приходит вот
при прикосновении прямо чувствует
перспективе это приведет к тому что
человек осознает что на фига тебе семья
взаимоотношения я создаю свою реальность
и то есть мета вселенная и 17 8
миллиардов людей у нас будет 8
миллиардов вселенной где каждый создает
то что ему интересно то что он хочет
соответственно все семени создаются дети
не рождаются население начнёт детей
разве планов
поехать на вопрос мой брат вопрос
времени и сейчас развита страна там там
вопрос 50 220 или давай прощаться
запустил спутники все интернет у всех
будет brother заполирован север от вот
вам телефоны за 10 долларов покупайте
все смотри и создавать этом своей
вселенной и вот и все весь мир стал
современными развитым к вид показал что
а
количество в этом году после к виды до
количество разводов резко снизилась во
всех странах мира практично ожидаем же
саверский вырос до потому что люди про
проводили время больше месте теперь
когда вот есть больше времени по
большому счету из тебя условно не надо
ехать время глаз в разводов увеличилась
велик нет количество разводов снизилась
резко снизилась посмотри статистике мне
поможете статистику сейчас да . а там
там был какой-то момент только в самом
начале а потом он на самом деле сильно
снизит просто люди стали гораздо больше
времени вместе проводить о чем больше
время вместе прочным отношение точно
укрепляется здесь судя по сути есть тоже
возможно с другой стороны до больше
времени проводить с детьми больше
времени проводить с любимым с родными
сначала чтобы это происходило надо чтобы
же сидит 17-летний стеснительный парень
который там мачо-мэн в настоящей жизнью
него скилла вообще пикапа нету у нас
была в молодости до
напишешь как это
рамиль вот я с тобой пол согласен ты
достаточно одного поколения для
поколений и для твоего форматов от
мышления людей такие как ты а ты уже
волнами да то есть человечество она
довольно успешно за всю историю себя
защищала от разных штук то есть есть
перед
какие-то перекосы в каждое время с
другой стороны какой-то момент люди
сыну-то подожди это что там ерунда все
до начинают где-то защищаться самое
будет то есть возможностей возможности
классные как и количество возможность
который появляется погоняет и михас все
знаете я вот здесь
возможно я не сильно популярен но мне и
так как раз скажет что люди не уйдут
больше чем процентов на 20-30
в мета вселенную с точки зрения вот
проведения там времени мне кажется да
мне кажется что к это будет во многом
это будет часто сквозь также как зум мы
все есть на условном мы в компании мы в
начале кайфовали когда к видно что даже
хорошо даже удобнее так далее сейчас у
нас вся эта если разворачивается прям
сильно разворачивается зум хорошо и
действительно как возможность процентов
10 20 это очень круто элементарным ты
опоздаешь на встречу теперь пойди ни
странно опасность навстречу по что вы ее
можете назначать или в электронном виде
да уже как бы никто не опоздает пойти
навстречу просто кто-то начнет и онлайн
закончить роммель это очень наивно
полагать что того что 20 процентов будет
там проблеме проводить вот представьте
если этого задаем 20 лет назад появилась
motorola если там тамошнему человек и
сказали бы что ты будешь мотороле сидеть
8 часов в день он штаты чуть больной что
ли ну максимум 20 процентов тебе
неадекватным будет сидеть сейчас возврат
население земли и сколько времени
проводит в телефоне
столько не проводят
зрения
мы будем работать до мне формацию для
размышления для обоих сторон смотрите
первая информация такая что вот
буквально перед сегодняшним откатом
прочитал эксперимент одного российского
санкт-петербургского психолога она
отобрала 67 детей и правила
экспериментов 8 часов кто дети чтобы не
пользовались гаджетами до конца
эксперимента дошли только трое одна
девочка два мальчика у
27 человек были симптомы тошноты и рвоты
головной боли один даже до потери
сознания и они описывали свои ощущения и
практически из 2067 64 ребенка не смогли
провести 8 часов сами с собой они не
знали что делать и они там пишут кто-то
рисовал кто-то прыгал спортом занимался
еще чуть пытался готовить кушать еще не
могли себя занять и в конце заканчивался
обязательно каким-то психологическим
срывам и это было катастрофически
эксперимента есть дети настолько уже
вжились в
социальные сети и когда вот ты сейчас
говоришь ты на самом деле даже право
поколения свое а вот вот эти дети я же
потом смотрю по
эволюции игр недавно буквально с одной
компании разговорила ними презентовали
доступную версию вот там шикарным там
как раз marketplace для продажи скинов
игру всё классно с моими ребятами ли я
грудной проблема в том же в том что
скины теперь эти кто будет пользоваться
дети теперь достоин доступные игры не
играет они все в мобильных сейчас
перешли уже дети
компьютеры не могут играть они не знают
как их регистрируют steam не
устанавливать образовались буквально
неделю назад купила ребенку виртуальный
дом
подошла да ему мертва мишу могу
носить недорогой полторы тысяч тенге
стал но к классным кстати мне он тоже
понравился то есть прям дом там куча
всякой мебели какие-то фишечки он прям
классно то рисованный виртуальный дом
забыл название игры вот приходится
сидеть тут новый появился а
потом старый дом уже будет не интересно
интересно это же вопрос дача твоей
реакции
родовая 2 я видел карикатуру где
она такая последовательно карикатурой
где когда человек сидит мечтает кто бы
мог ему сделать вот это вот это в этот и
он изобретает технологию и думает что
вот эти гаджеты будут нашими рабами там
сделай вот это сделай это сделает то
сделать то а потом следующая картинка
где он раб и этот гаджет и мне говорит
заряди меня сделай апдейт of great
загрузи новую версию купи новую модель и
так далее так далее то есть мы
становимся рабами технологий но с другой
стороны
здесь вопрос опять таки это вопрос
морали вот я замечаю что каждый раз мы
упираемся вопрос моргана вопрос
воспитания мира сами как бы ты видел
метавселенной
[музыка]
какие мог бы ты хотел на твои вопросы
никакими наверное все таки в количестве
их будет много и будет из чего выбирать
то есть как вот сейчас вот например
выбор можем там не знаем выбирать
идеологию под которым мы подписываемся
да то есть одна более демократической а
другая более то не знаю к китайской и
так далее то же самое то есть у нас
будет такая как как с религии кстати у
нас же ну то есть очень много религий
каждый может подписаться под любую то же
самое есть да я что я хочу видеть я хочу
видеть вот эту как стать молчите
этих момент rss да и в этом-то и есть
как бы демократии выбора человека что
наверно это которая там была создана
фейсбуком она лучше там регулируется там
что-то правильно там не знаю как то
отсеивает контент который там какой-то
там новой лэнс там
гречку и так далее так далее будет
другая которая там не знаю создана
где-то в более других и
вот вот такую наверное хотел видеть ее
родители будут смотря на например какой
сидит там ребенок как-то более дождись и
самим не разбирать и льна будут знать
как бы какие там не знаю импликации есть
от нахождения там той или иной
можно ваших комментарий
уже 4 самой крупной мета вселенной
созданный это так но простоты знания они
созданы они существуют и уже готовится
мост для взаимодействия между этими
четырьмя медалями сейчас готовится
проектом еще не вышел хочет сделать
которой буфер сальные язык 4 все эти
соединять и потом соединяете больше
больше больше поделать и
пространства-времени кажется будто бы ну
или до конгломерат таких больших
ответственных компаний все равно же все
большие компании хотят для своего таргет
аудитории да например как apple да там у
них корпуса жил responsibility там и так
далее и так далее все равно
свободный рынок свободной рыночной
экономики ведет к тому что но люди будут
хотеть и они будут предоставлять вот это
все это хорошее администрирования то
есть блокирование каких-то там
[музыка]
перестрелок и так далее и так далее то
есть но такой будет какой-то крупный
гигант который будет это свобода выбора
буграми
очень вдохновлен тем что это может дать
с точки зрения образования
вот я прям представляю как в каком
интересном формате
я не знаю ты можешь там условно
виртуально пообщаться с эйнштейном или
там с тем джобса пример да то есть
какой-то самый крутой преподавателя
математики в мире может преподавать
каждому школьнику на планете это будет
весело и прикольно сделано до 7 кажется
это с точки зрения такова
мультипликативного эффекта и в
здравоохранении тоже сама история думаю
возможно в итоге у тебя будет очень
много очень продвинутого населения будет
страшно и конкуренция знаний вот ну в
целом да это возможность для мне кажется
бедных стран преуспеть рвануть за счет
качества человеческого капитала очень
быстро в этом смысле опять
демократизация произойдет да то есть
возможности действительно мне кажется
будут
равны шаг равные возможности и шаг
наверно какой то персонализации
действительно да то есть тоже вопрос
того как ты сделаешь может и себе там
поставишь какие-то фильтры ты хочешь
действительно видеть всех только
красивыми самому блядская силу в черном
зеркале есть еще серия прикольная
интересная там как два чувака они
встретились в типа виртуальной
реальности
полюбили друг друга и так далее хотя не
вообще-то два парня в жизни а там они
были не парнями там они были парни
девушка да я забыл что за серия но
концептуально это же такое немножко
разрыв мозга вот условно если там
условно ты там не не не очень жизни но
почему бы тебе не быть успешным хотя бы
так опять же я не знаю но почему это
плохо не знаю плохо ли это на самом деле
может хорошо это плохо это обман обман
всегда плохо
игрофикация он все в итоге приведет к
чему-то такому катастрофическому да то
есть мы когда корчит из себя то что мы
не являемся но потом каком-то таком
white and эти крайзис нас приводит но
мне кажется я не за я не психолог я
возможно здесь сам хорошим здесь на
самом деле не факт что именно произойдет
где dice 13 фикации то есть смотрите
каждый человек течение жизни выполняет
много ролей и не каждый человек до конца
знает какая роль его настоящее
поэтому вишь ты можешь считать что в
этой жизни ты это есть твоя идентичность
а когда ты зайдешь виртуальном
пространстве тычут почувствовал что-то
герой ты кайфанул и ты понимаешь что
настоящий я это там вон тот я настоящий
ты понимаешь в чем дело и пройдя
произведет наоборот в том что ты
дыбы дымке фиксируешь свою
оффлайнового личность тело что нет
настоящей я все-таки там просто в этой
жизни не видали проявиться в школе был
буллинг родители были такие то недодали
образовали что-то у меня в жизни не
получилось и так далее вот а настоящая
мои внутренние нутру настоящая на жизнь
может быть там но тогда потом запустил
настоящее тело не знаю там до диабета до
ожирения и до чего
как мы опять упирается моральную дилемму
когда человек может сказать а зачем мне
такая жизнь
либо вода жизнь либо зачем мне такая
жизнь то есть и закончить жизнь многие
скажут же зачем мне такая так то же
самое как сейчас многие говорят зачем
мне развиваться зачем мне читать книги а
зачем я я хочу пить мне был образно не
смотрите это же вопрос когда так не было
я сейчас же основная заметьте сейчас
самая востребованная профессия в мире
это психолог у
это не только из-за к вида а из за того
что на самом деле вот эти социальные
сети много соблазнов и везде пишут что
там заработали миллиарды тот это только
везде красивая одежда в машины и так
далее и люди чувствуют себя неудачниками
депрессия мировая болезнь ну почему
потому что смотри у депрессии много
корней огромный выбор кривой депрессии
это уже учеными доказано трудно сделать
выбор это принять решение куча мозговой
энергии потратьте этой цели у нас сейчас
огромный выбор товаров огромный выбор
социальных сетей огромный выбор общения
огромный выбор ну просто информации
всего-всего-всего и выбрать что-то
тяжело и еще есть же синдром упущенный
упущенных возможностей это офферов
местам и человек думает блин я сейчас
выберу а это брюс вдруг не
поможет смотреть на вопросы супер
много завел
давайте ребята вот где будет
какой-нибудь продвинутый лучше мировой
психолог у каждого персональный суд но
хорошо но получается там будет не живой
человек за ним сети какой то и я и вот
какой то не знаю как в колл-центре
вот я думаю
интеллект и вот этого хватит слушая а
мне кажется что у всех людей плюс-минус
проблем похоже почему психологи
собственно успешны потому что они они же
не в моменте придумывает какие-то
решения согласия не вид одни и те же
кейсы просто для человек этот типа о
капец какая проблема для психолога то и
миллион раз такое видела так надо делать
а поэтому ну может это не проблема стук
я скорее всего нет да пошли вспомнил что
вот я когда в университете учился ли 12
назад там этот читал
книгу по саморазвитию по makin есть
такой британский
гипнотизер но это есть тут же вещь во
первых то что он пишет настолько
универсально нас что настолько 10
применимо принципе ко всем а во вторых
еще даже не среди того что написано мы
сжечь мы же люди обращаем внимание у нас
же есть конформаций боясь мы обращаем
внимание на то что нам нужно что у нас
болит что у нас этот поэтому я думаю что
какой то и я в принципе или какие-то за
исписаны скрипты могут быть достаточно
сама интересно насчет психология еще
разобрать это слово до по кусочкам это
учение о душе психует а душа но
современные психологи не говорят о душе
ни слова они говорят больше о
эмоциях о поступках да там твои мозги и
поведенческих факторах и в этом одна из
проблем а что мы не изучаем душу мы
говорим о виртуальной реальности в
разрезе только этой жизни мы верим а
почему нельзя обманываться то человеку
плохо говорит точнее хорошо да пусть
обманет пусть он создал себе какой-то
там аватар а то ему хорошо но если мы
говорим о вопросе о человеке с
перспективой там вечность кидаетесь если
говорить мне в душу туда может быть
здесь ему хорошо мы там вечно жизнь
будет ему очень не так хорошо поэтому я
начали свое выступление с рассказал что
для меня виртуальная реальность это
обман это большой обман и эти темные
силы так сказать мирового масштаба
пытается сделать все что угодно чтобы
отвлечь нас от этого реального мира a
person is группа людей которые также как
собрать массовая бронсона голоса есть
смысл жизни какой то есть предназначение
человека есть тут почему мы сюда
приходим в этот мир и все эти моем
понимании да мне-то вселенной могут быть
инструментов чтобы отвлечь нас от всего
конечно плюсы есть образование это
путешествие там и так далее но я честно
как родители я сделаю все возможное
чтобы моего ребенка
отдалить именно от входа в этому
метавселенную сделаю все возможно бы
ограничить его нахождение виртуальном
мире и сделать все возможное чтобы
реальный мир был для моих детей
интереснее веселее и привлекательнее и
красивее чем виртуальный мир итог такой
давайте давайте потихоньку подводить
итоги не смотрите подводя итоги наверное
я скажу такую вещь что во-первых прежде
всего спасибо за ваше участие в
сегодняшней дискуссии интересное
дело в том что мы наверное я не знаю
насколько мы ошиблись или нет мы взяли
слишком большую тему и вот и темы просто
огромное количество аспектов можно было
бы даже один срез весь вечер говорить об
одном связи там эта вселенная и работаем
эта вселенная и игры метро вселенной и
мораль там и так далее так далее эта
вселенная и бизнес реклама и так далее
но мы как бы прошлись в целом по
всеми то вселенной бунты gt
потрогали ее со всех сторон
где-то расширили свои горизонты
надеешься для наших зрителей тоже что-то
было полезно но я считаю смотрите в
целом миссии резюмируя наверное скажу
что каждый по-своему все равно будет
понимать метавселенную это наверное
факты плюс мета вселенной наверное будут
их много и они 1 это ясно третий момент
что эта вселенная будет состоять из
нескольких частей одна часть обязательно
к посещению как условно
[музыка]
регистрационные дела и голые там и так
далее которые я будущем надеюсь перейдут
на блокчейн и и так далее если
государственным позволит хотя там тоже
вопросов много вообще в целом всегда
конечно можно смотреть что одна часть
это возможности но мы всегда даже знать
что против этих возможностей ровно
столько же стоит рисков вот ровно
столько же мы говорим про то что мне это
вселенной это ништяк всё классно
обличает нашу жизнь но мы не видим
многих вещей где она нам усложняет и на
самом деле может привести к катастрофе
это вечная борьба между оптимизмом
пессимизмом и
поэтому ясно что мы точно не можем дать
точный прогноз что это для нас блага или
нет это наверно зрители должны
отводиться me но самое главное я хотел
бы отметить это я где-то соглашусь с
hud'ом в том что мета вселенные ставят
нас и как человеческий вид как
человеческую расу ставить сейчас нас на
ребро и
мы должны сделать моральный выбор сами
потому что большинство людей и вообще я
так сказал вся наша экономика чат
построено на том чтобы что-то иметь
иметь багаца имеет дом имеет машину
иметь друга хорошего иметь хорошую жену
и так далее но никто не хочет быть быть
хорошим другом быть хорошим мужем быть
ответственным миллиардером или
быть богатым человеком ответственным
которые несет риски все и так далее то
есть люди быть не хотят иметь хотят и к
сожалению вся цифровая экономика вся
реклама вся построен на том что
управляет нашими страстями и нашими
страхами а это по исламу основные
инструменты шайтана шайтан год человеком
управляет через две вещи через страх и
через страсть и к сожалению тот и прочь
мы подошли к созданию мета вселенной как
к созданию атомной бомбы то есть мы
подошли к огромные вещи которые может
поменять нашу жизнь мораль все но
морально мы подошли не с теми
ориентирами то же самое мы в свое время
подошли к созданию атомной бомбы мы ее
создали
но люди еще не были готовы то есть
человек создал оружие разрушительное
оружие которому могло разрушить всю
человеческую цивилизацию и мета
вселенная считаю это хоть и не и оружие
но по сокрушительная способность имеет
такую же вещь и вопрос морального выбора
это основной вопрос вот сегодня мы
затрагивали и воспитание детей и семья и
бизнес частично и так далее в конечном
итоге это не вопрос технологии это не
вопрос блокчейн кмф ты крипты это
виртуальные очки виртуальной реальности
и так далее это на самом деле происходит
огромный сдвиг вообще парадигмы и
вот мы говорили о том что вы насчет
браков в виртуальных детей это все
моральный выбор мы конечно не сможем и
не смогли бы даже ответить сегодняшнем
за сегодняшнем столом на эти глобальные
вопросы наверное этим вопросом и адресу
нашей аудитории
цель нашей сегодняшней дискуссии была
прийти на гимпу поднять проблему
попытаться найти корень этой проблемы но
мы по моему даже ухудшились
сейчас все выглядит гораздо запутать
сейчас было в начале вечера но не важно
важно что и 1 деюсь мы дали эту затравку
благодаря которой люди начнут заду отца
и
по крайней мере в своей жизни делать
правильный моральный выбор спасибо до
встречи в следующих выпусках нашего
подкаста gemma подкаст до свидания
[музыка]